[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui que de nouveaux
éléments deviennent publiques
relativement à lenquête de l'upac qui
concerne les fuites d'informations
policières se souvient que cet automne
l'upac a mené des perquisitions chez les
policiers richard despatie et stéphane
bonhomme et à arrêter le député libéral
guy ouellette et faut dire il ya
toujours aucune accusation n'a été
portée contre les trois hommes
c'est vrai et cette enquête frappe
l'imagination ça fait couler énormément
d'encre
même si l'enquêté pas encore terminée et
ce soir nous vous présentons les
allégations qui sont au coeur de cette
enquête une enquête qui est vraiment
digne d'un roman
on vous prévient ce sont les prétentions
des policiers y ont rien de tout ça qui
a encore été prouvées devant les
tribunaux c'est une histoire de filature
qui met en scène des politiciens des
journalistes des chefs de police des
personnages clés nommé à la commission
charbonneau une histoire qui mène à
l'une des arrestations les plus
médiatisés qu'a connu l'assemblée
nationale celle du député guy ouellette
contre qui aucune accusation n'a été
encore porté trois mois plus tard on
accuse tout qu'on s'excuse
j'avais raison de vous poser des
questions vous avez aussi raison d'être
troublé par les événements nous sommes
également les députés de chemin des est
soupçonné d'avoir obtenu ou tenter
d'obtenir des informations
confidentielles de membres de l'upac
pour l'écouler à des journalistes
aujourd'hui une large part du document
qui a mené à la perquisition au d'une de
ses résidences et rendue publique
il nous permet de raconter les motifs
des policiers leur version de l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre cette histoire il
faut remonter au 17 mars 2016
ces jours du dépôt du budget à
l'assemblée nationale
mais l'attention médiatique est ailleurs
une bombe politique a été larguée l'upac
lâche une bombe
nathalie normandeau et marc yvan côté
arrêté pour fraude et corruption
c'est l'aboutissement de deux enquêtes
dont une qui a débuté presque cinq ans
plus tôt et qui vise l'attribution de
subventions gouvernementales
c'est la première fois que l'upac
l'unité permanente anticorruption frappe
aussi haut en arrêtant une membre du
gouvernement qui plus est l'ex vice
première ministre
à l'ère de jean charest marc yvan côté
un important organisateur libéral lui
aussi en ses ministres et co-accusé dans
le cadre de ces enquêtes
l'upac a mis la main sur des
communications entre marc yvan côté et
sam hamad
un ministre en poste mais deux semaines
après les arrestations de nathalie
normandeau et marc yvan côté coup de
théâtre
[Musique]
les courriels que nous avons obtenu
donne un accès inédit aux tractations en
coulisses l'émission enquête diffuse des
informations sur leurs échanges par
courriel au sujet de l'attribution de
subventions et courriels indique que sam
hamad continuent d'informer marty van
kote sur ses démarches auprès
d'investissement québec
notre premier à faciliter défendant
après-midi la sphère fait grand bruit à
l'assemblée nationale sam hamad quittera
le conseil des ministres je souhaitais
que la situation ne devienne pas une
distraction pour l'action
gouvernementale et le premier ministre
dans les jours qui suivent
c'est autour d'un mystérieux pierre de
défrayer les manchettes dans un article
de l'actualité intitulé qui veut faire
dérailler le procès de nathalie
normandeau
pierre raconte aux journalistes que la
preuve est mince pour accusé l'ex vice
première ministre
il semble bien informés sur les enquêtes
en cours
ce pierre on le comprend maintenant dans
les documents rendus publics sera au
coeur de la sphère guy ouellette les
documents relèvent qu'il connaît bien
les rouages du gouvernement et qu'il
déclare aux journalistes que le sort du
patron de l'upac robert lafrenière est
scellé selon pierre philippe couillard
non voudrait plus
malgré ce qu'en dit pierre le mandat de
robert lafrenière est renouvelé
mais la pression continuera de monter
sur multaq pour que d'autres enquêtes
aboutissent
un an plus tard quelqu'un d'autre ajoute
son grain de sel
lino zambito témoin vedette de la
commission charbonneau
trois ans après son témoignage il a
plaidé coupable à des accusations de
complot et de corruption
pouvoir tourner la page mais toutes ces
épisodes lorient les policiers le
considère maintenant comme témoin dans
l'enquêté ma chérie sur l'ancien premier
ministre jean charest et l'ex argentier
du parti libéral du québec marc bibeau
aujourd'hui les documents nous
apprennent qu'il est dans la mire de
l'upac pour les fuites dans les médias
4 à 5 4 1 puis moins d'informations sur
l'étang monde vit ça j'ai déjà trouvé un
mix bab al sultan suite
puis vient une nouvelle révélation
la goutte qui fait déborder le vase de
l'upac l'ex premier ministre jean
charest et l'ex grand argentier libéral
marc bibeau ont fait l'objet de
surveillances policières au moins
jusqu'en 2016 alors félix
à quelques jours de la convocation
annuel de robert lafrenière devant les
élus de l'assemblée nationale quebecor
dévoile des détails pointus du projet
machuret ce qui met le commissaire dans
l'embarras
les enquêteurs du commissaire robert
lafrenière ont obtenu de l'agencé des
services frontaliers la liste de
dizaines de passages de bebo et charest
aux douanes canadiennes depuis 2003 ils
ont aussi obtenu une copie du passeport
de jean charest des fiches détaillées
des deux hommes qui contiennent
notamment des informations familiale et
bancaire personnel que des corps selon
la fille david diffuse des documents
couverts par le privilège de l'anc est
en cours
quand ces documents se retrouvent dans
les bulletins de nouvelles c'est tout le
travail de l'upac et le temps qu'elle
met à faire avancer les enquêtes qui est
questionnée
yann forte odeur de pourriture qui émane
de toutes ces révélations
ça fait en sorte qu'on a encore un
gouvernement libéral qui n'a pas rendu
des comptes sur ces sur la corruption
des moeurs politiques dont le suspect
numéro un est monsieur charest à la
suite de la diffusion de ces reportages
l'upac déploiera les grands moyens
aujourd'hui l'upac a déclenché une
enquête interne pour connaître l'origine
de la fuite de documents confidentiels
qui a mené à ces révélations
dans les documents il est écrit le
mandat qui nous a été confiée et
d'enquêté sur le vol de documents d'une
enquête en cours
l'abus de confiance l' entrave et les
infractions criminelles qui sont
associés note ric et n'enquête pas sur
les sources journalistiques ou les
journalistes
dix jours après la diffusion des
reportages de quebecor robert lafrenière
se présente l'air déterminé à
l'assemblée nationale pour s'adresser à
la commission des institutions
il affirme que l'anc est mature et n'est
pas morte et il est à la recherche de
ceux qui ont coulé des informations aux
journalistes
je souhaite ardemment qu'on arrive à une
conclusion est qu'on trouve le bandji
quand il prononce ces mots celui à qui
il s'adresse le président de cette
commission
c'est nul autre que guy ouellette ce
qu'on comprend aujourd'hui à la lecture
des documents
c'est que guy ouellette était déjà une
personne d'intérêt dans l' enquête de
l'upac dans l'affidavit on lit qu'un
enquêteur de la sûreté du québec qui l'a
rencontré à dix à l'upac guy ouellette
confirme qu'il n'a pas parlé à des
journalistes concernant les appels du
dénommé pierre
ce ne sera pas assez pour lui pas qu un
an plus tard c'est son téléphone qui
fera l'objet d'un mandat pour obtenir la
liste de ces appels éventuellement lui
parle demandera aussi de perquisitionner
sa résidence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
l'affidavit qui a mené à la perquisition
chez guy ouellette nous révèle pour la
première fois les détails d'une enquête
qui a mobilisé plus d'une dizaine de
policiers qui ont colligé des
informations couvrant une période de
deux ans la centaine de pages n'explique
pas clairement pourquoi l'attention de
l'upac s'est porté sur le député
lui-même un ancien policier de la sûreté
du québec
mais ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'en
épluchant ses registres d'appels et de
messages textes l'upac a ciblé certaines
personnes avec qui il est en contact
notamment lino zambito et deux policiers
richard despatie analystes enquêteur de
l'upac jusqu en octobre 2016 et stéphane
bonhomme policier au service des
enquêtes sur la corruption selon
l'affidavit tous deux ont accès à des
documents strictement confidentiel de
l'upac qui pourrait avoir été acheminés
aux journalistes l'affidavit révèle que
l'upac recense tous les reportages
publiés à propos de ces enquêtes en
tentant d'établir une concordance entre
le moment de leur publication et les
contacts téléphoniques des suspects dans
le cas du mystérieux pierre par exemple
l'enquêteur va jusqu'à conclure gély
motifs raisonnables et probables de
croire que richard despatie et pierre et
a en sa possession des informations dans
quel du projet machuret ithaque passe
ainsi au peigne fin les appels de guy
ouellette notamment ceux effectués le
jour du fameux face à face où elle est
la fronière qu'à 15 heures nous serons
salon bleu pendant la suspension des
travaux
guy ouellette communique avec au moins
une personne qui va susciter l'intérêt
de l'upac
le grand patron de la sûreté du québec
martin prud'homme qui est lui même dans
la salle leurs échanges vont
éventuellement faire l'objet de
questions de l'upac
c'est martin prud'homme qui demande
d'abord de rencontrer l'upac
mais la sphère est sensible ce sont des
policiers de la sûreté du québec
donc qu'ils sont sous l'autorité
administrative de martin prud'homme qui
travaillent pour lui pâques afin de
dissiper l'apparence de conflit
d'intérêts
l'upac demande l'assistance de la grc
selon les récits des policiers deux
rencontres ont eu lieu marqué plus
d'hommes défend son intégrité
même s'il est le conjoint de dominique
lafreniere la fille de robert lafrenière
il affirme n'avoir aucun lien avec les
gens de l'upac aparté liens familiaux
il dit ne pas savoir ce que l'upac fait
il y à un mur entre les deux entités
paradoxalement c'est par l'entremise de
son directeur général adjoint à la
sûreté du québec qu'il a appris
l'existence de l'anc est en lien avec le
problème de coulage ainsi que
l'implication potentielle de guy
ouellette
ils confirment qu'ils se connaissent
depuis qu'ils ont tous deux travaillé à
la sûreté du québec en 1992
martin prud'homme déclare que c'est
normal que guy ouellette l'appel guy
ouellette a un très grand réseau il
parle à beaucoup de monde en plus de
leurs liens professionnels
martin prud'homme ajoutera plus tard
qu'ils ont aussi des liens personnels en
2007 2008 ils se sont vus plus
fréquemment car lorsqu'il était à
l'extérieur de la ville
la conjointe de l'époque de monsieur
ouellette s'occupait de la conjointe de
monsieur prudhomme qui était gravement
malade
les deux couples entretenait des
relations amicales
il est convaincu que le député est
honnête
guy ouellette n'a jamais essayé de lui
soutirer des informations
il se dit tout de même préoccupé par
rapport à la façon dont il doit se
comporter avec lui il dit je ne suis pas
un agent source
je ne mettrai pas de micros les agents
rencontrent à nouveau le patron de la
sûreté du québec
huit jours avant l'arrestation de guy
ouellette il avise qu'il est considéré
comme témoin pour clarifier certains
points durant cette rencontre
l'upac note que selon le patron de la
escu c'est un fait connu que pour des
raisons personnelles monsieur ouellette
et monsieur robert lafrenière ne
s'apprécient pas martin prud'homme
serait cependant très surpris
d'apprendre que monsieur guy ouellette
fait couler de l'information relative à
des enquêtes active de l'upac
quand martin prud'homme fait ces
déclarations
l'enquète s'est encore étendue mais
policiers de l'upac ont obtenu la
permission de scruter les registres
d'appels de deux autres personnes
notamment annie trudel c'est avec
soulagement que je me retrouve devant
fou en espérant avoir l'opportunité
d'éclaircir certains événements si ce
nom vous dit quelque chose c'est que
vous l'avez vu dénoncer des situations
irrégulières au ministère des transports
lors d'une commission parlementaire qui
a elle aussi défrayé les manchettes en
avril 2005 il ya plusieurs stratagèmes
pour en fait faire indirectement ce
qu'on peut pas faire directement
l'origine à tarascon on se penche sur
tout ce stratagème la ola aussi vu
quelques reprises accompagné guy
ouellette lors d'événements publics
leurs registres d'appels de son
téléphone sera un des derniers à faire
l'objet d'un mandat mais la fille david
caviardé n'est pas clair quant à sa
potentielle implication et le nom dany
trudel n'apparaît pas dans la liste des
personnes qui auraient commis les
infractions alléguées
il nous apprend seulement qu'elle aurait
manifesté son intérêt à discuter d'une
certification iso anti corruption ainsi
qu'à travailler pour l'upac
anne itto d'elles a dit publiquement
avoir été intercepté par l'upac la
journée de l'arrestation de guy
ouellette pour pour destruction preuves
mais la fille david ne le mentionne pas
élu bac n'a jamais commenter cette
affirmation
quant à l'arrestation du député les
documents démontrent que la séquence des
événements était rodé au quart de tour
à 9h15 à brossard un agent saisi le
téléphone de l'ex enquêteur
richard despatie l'objectif recherché
par les policiers de prétendre être
richard despatie ils veulent laisser
croire qu'il possède un autre scoop
pouvant intéresser guy ouellette dans
les heures qui suivent plusieurs
messages sont échangées avec guy
ouellette
ils sont complètement caviardé dans les
documents à 12h56 août et morton de
laurier-station un policier dépose un
sac derrière une borne pour recharger
les voitures électriques
à l'intérieur se trouvent des feuilles
blanches à 13h39
guy ouellette ci présente récupère le
sac et retourne vers sa voiture
il est alors arrêtés sans mandat son
cellulaire est saisi et mis sous scellé
sans consulter son contenu selon les
documents le document rendu public
aujourd'hui a ensuite permis de
perquisitionner sa résidence par la
suite
l'upac s'est défendu d'avoir tendu un
piège à guy ouellette
il est véhiculé il s'agit d'un piège il
s'agit plutôt d'un appât lino zambito
vichard despatie stéphane bonhomme et
guy ouellette tous visés par cette
enquête ont nié catégoriquement avoir
participé à des fuites médiatiques
les documents rendus publics aujourd'hui
lève un peu plus le voile sur la sphère
guy ouellette
mais il manque encore des clés pour tout
comprendre des clés que seul un procès
pourrait procurer à ce jour aucune
accusation n'a été portée et les
allégations de l'upac n'ont pas été
testés en cours
[Musique]